muy bien hoy vamos a estar hablando
acerca de la granja no anteriormente
hablamos acerca de los multiplicadores
de la granja y este nuevo concepto de la
granja no es un concepto que está muy
relacionado con los multiplicadores de
la granja de hecho no nos está enseñando
nada nuevo simplemente es aplicar lo que
ya sabíamos de una forma un poco más
sencilla y compacta así que para
recordarles la configuración del
ejercicio de optimización con
restricciones del cual estábamos
hablando voy a escribir de nuevo aquí
una función voy a escribir de nuevo que
aquí teníamos una cierta función f
de x y una función multi variable y
bueno esta función era igual am y no
sean se me ocurren x cuadrada que
multiplica a m elevado a la gent x gent
y lo que tenemos aquí mostrado son las
curvas de nivel para esta función
entonces decimos qué pasa si
establecemos esta función igual a una
cierta constante y bueno si escojo una
constante entonces
vamos a ver unas ciertas curvas de nivel
pero sí cambios de constante si escoge
una constante diferente entonces esta
curva del nivel puede verse un poco
diferente pero observa que es agradable
que tengan formas parecidas entonces
esta es la función y estamos tratando de
maximizar la el objetivo es maximizar
esta función x bien así que déjame
escribirlo
el objetivo era maximizar la y por
supuesto no sólo eso la razón por la
cual llamamos a este ejercicio un
ejercicio de optimización con
restricción es porque tienen una cierta
restricción vamos a tener otra función
llamada la función gm que también es una
función desde x ideye que me va a dar
todos los posibles valores que puede
tomar x james igualada a una cierta
cantidad así que en este caso voy a
decir que gm de clic en esta función
x cuadrada más cuadrada y lo voy a hacer
igual a una cierta constante voy a
hacerlo igual
por lo tanto no podemos tomar cualquier
valor que se nos ocurran de equis de ye
justo aquí para maximizar esta función
tenemos que cumplir también la
restricción de que x cuadrada malla
cuadrada tiene que ser igual a 4 y hable
acerca de esto en los últimos vídeos
sobre algunas de las cosas fantásticas
que encontramos una de ellas fue que al
ver las diferentes curvas de nivel de
efe el máximo sería alcanzado cuando esa
curva de nivel sea perfectamente
paralela a la curva del nivel de g y un
ejemplo bastante clásico que habíamos
visto de eso es cuando esta función
efe le poníamos el nombre de r era la
función r que era mi función de ingreso
el ingreso que obtiene una cierta
compañía no sé ustedes están modelando
sus ingresos basados en diferentes
gestiones que podrían hacer dirigiendo
justo esa compañía y a esta función
restricción en lugar de llamarla gm le
poníamos el nombre de la función de la
función que cumplían un cierto
presupuesto entonces lo que estamos
tratando de hacer
es maximizar el ingreso que entra a tu
compañía limitado a un cierto
presupuesto es decir lo que estás
dispuesto a gastar y bueno todas estas
funciones son ficticias nunca tendrás un
presupuesto que se viera como un círculo
y esta es una configuración aleatoria
para tu ingreso pero en principio
ustedes saben a lo que me refiero así
que la manera en la que sacamos provecho
de esto es que si tenemos la propiedad
de la tangencia imagínate que esta es la
curva y que por acá nos tomamos a la
otra curva
imagínate esta otra curva ambas son
tangentes en un punto entonces el punto
donde las dos funciones son tangentes
entre sí me dicen que el vector
gradiente donde las curvas son tangentes
el vector gradiente de esta función r
déjame ponerle nombre éste es el vector
gradiente de la función r este va a ser
paralelo o proporcional al vector de a
diente de nuestra función restricción al
gradiente de nuestra función restricción
que en este caso es el gradiente
esta función ven y lo que significa es
que cuando quieres resolver un tipo de
ejercicio de optimización con
restricciones entonces vas a fijarte en
que el gradiente de esta función r no va
a ser forzosamente igual al gradiente de
esta función bem va a ser proporcional
entonces si pongo aquí el gradiente de
esta función ven hay que multiplicar por
una cierta constante ya esa constante le
poníamos el nombre de lambda que era
justo el multiplicador de lagrange
entonces el gradiente del ingreso es
proporcional al grado ente del
presupuesto e hicimos un par de
ejercicios resolviendo este tipo de
cosas porque recuerda esto nos daban dos
ecuaciones que utilizaban derivadas
parciales y después teníamos una tercera
ecuación que era justo está la ecuación
de la restricción ahora bien él la
granja no que es justo lo que queremos
estudiar en este vídeo es una manera de
resolver esta misma ecuación junto con
la ecuación
en una sola entidad así que si lo
piensas en esa manera no estamos
añadiendo información nueva pero lo que
sí es que vamos a simplificar bastante
las cosas que hacemos a mano y sobre
todo va a ser más sencillo si hacemos
esto a computadora así que voy a
mostrarte a qué me refiero la forma en
la que defino la granja no es con esta
el lector si va va a ser una función
multi variable que va a tener las mismas
entradas que tienen la función que queda
es maximizar y tu función de restricción
x y james pero además va a tener una
nueva variable la otra variable que va a
tener va a ser lambda lambda así que
esta es la forma en la que vamos a
definir el a granjean o la manera en la
que lo definimos es la siguiente te vas
a tomar la función que quieres maximizar
la función de ingreso tal cual con las
mismas variables es decir agarras a efe
que depende de x
y que depende de iu ya esto le vas a
quitar lambda veces y aquí están porque
incluimos la lambda en el la granja no
le vamos a quitar lambda veces que
multiplique a la función restricción es
decir la función del presupuesto de de x
100 ok
fíjate que tenemos las mismas entradas
que en pm y a esto le vamos a quitar el
valor al que esté igualada la función en
este caso el valor es 4 aquí lo puedes
ver es 4 o bueno tal vez lo podemos ver
de manera más general de la siguiente
manera si en lugar de 4 aquí pongo no
sea cualquier número es decir le pongo
be cualquier número entonces a esto le
tendremos que quitar b
ibm es una constante así que esta es la
forma en la que voy a definir este la
granja no observan que es una función
multi variable tienes
x allí involucrados tanto en la función
r como la función ven y tienes a lambda
que está multiplicando a esta diferencia
y bueno es una función multi variable
que depende de x de jay y de lambda
porque esta vez constante por lo tanto
no depende de esta vez así que déjame
especificarlo esta vez de aquí es sólo
una constante y tal vez esto te parece
una cosa bastante rara y un poco
aleatoria sobre todo si lo ves fuera de
contexto pero yo pienso que es algo
bastante estupendo y vamos a continuar y
trabajar con esta función para que veas
a lo que me refiero porque ahora lo que
vamos a querer es hacer el gradiente de
stella granjean o el gradiente de toda
esta función que tengo aquí
esto igual am el vector 0 déjame ponerlo
con este color es el vector 0 y gracias
a esto vamos a obtener las tres
ecuaciones que obteníamos en los vídeos
anteriores y éstas van a salir de
calcular el gradiente de l porque el
gradiente va a ser un vector de tres
entradas diferentes voy a tener la
derivada parcial de la granja no con
respecto a x la derivada parcial de la
granja no con respecto a james y la
derivada parcial de la granja no con
respecto a lambda porque son nuestras
tres entradas que estamos considerando
en esta función así que déjame
escribirlo esto va a ser lo mismo que y
lo voy a poner con este color la
derivada parcial de m l con respecto
primero a x ok después tengo la derivada
parcial de l con respecto ayer y por
último tengo la derivada parcial d
con respecto a la vda así que lo voy a
escribir así y bueno si hago este vector
igual al vector 0 lo que realmente estoy
diciendo es que cada una de estas
componentes va a ser igual a 0 estás de
acuerdo esta componente va a ser igual a
0 esta componente va a ser igual a 0 y
esta otra componente también va a ser
igual a 0 es decir lo que estoy diciendo
es que cada una de estas ecuaciones va a
ser igual a 0 y tal vez lo encuentres
así como una negrita en los libros de
texto tal vez encuentres como una flecha
en los libros de texto no realmente está
hablando del vector 0 entonces estas
tres derivadas parciales las vamos a
hacer iguales a cero todas ahora piensen
un poco de esto que son las derivadas
parciales bueno pues vamos a calcular la
primera vamos a calcular déjame ponerlo
con este color la derivada parcial de él
con respecto a x con respecto a x bueno
pues esto va a ser igual y observa aquí
tenemos primero la función r que depende
de x entonces me quedarían déjame
ponerlo con su respectivo color me va a
quedar como la derivada parcial de esta
función r con respecto a x ya esto le
voy a quitar y ahora observa lambda
cuando te digo con respecto a x me
parece como una constante es simplemente
una constante así que es una constante
que multiplica a lo que está acá adentro
es una constante que va a multiplicar a
bueno la derivada de esto que tengo aquí
adentro ahora quién es la derivada de
esto que tengo aquí adentro si observas
primero tengo la derivada de esta
función p
con respecto a x porque esta función ver
depende de x entonces me quedaría la
derivada parcial de b con respecto a x
y después tengo la derivada de b con
respecto a x pero b es una constante
entonces se eliminan simplemente me
quedaría 0 la derivada de una constante
con respecto a x es 0 entonces se va así
que ésta va a ser la derivada de la
granja no con respecto a x y xi esto lo
hacemos igual a cero observamos que es
lo mismo que tomarme la derivada de r
con respecto a x igual a lambda veces la
derivada de b con respecto a x que si
recuerdas en los vídeos pasados era
justo la primera componente que nos
tomábamos cuando hablábamos de esta
función que tengo aquí del gradiente de
r igual a lambda veces el gradiente de b
entonces nos daría la primera porción de
esta parte que habíamos visto en otros
vídeos la primera componente de esto
sería la derivada parcial de r con
respecto a x igual a lambda veces la
derivada parcial de ver con respecto a x
que es justo lo que tenemos y si hacemos
con otro color
derivada de l con respecto a 10 observa
que vamos a obtener algo muy similar con
respecto a yemen esto va a ser igual
bueno primero vamos a derivar esta
función r
con respecto a yemen entonces me queda
la derivada parcial de r con respecto a
ok
- ya esto le vamos a quitar lambda veces
porque lambda zona constante lambda que
multiplica a y bueno va a ser algo muy
parecido
tengo la derivada de b con respecto a
gem la derivada parcial de b con
respecto ayer y si derivamos una
constante bueno con respecto ayer o con
respecto a x esos 0
entonces si hago esto igual a cero
observa que estoy obteniendo la segunda
componente de esta parte que tengo aquí
del gradiente de r igual a lambda veces
el gradiente de bem porque si esto es
igual a cero me quedaría que la derivada
parcial de r con respecto a eso
a lambda a veces la derivada de b con
respecto ayer lo único que está pasando
es que este gradiente de aquí está
trayendo del otro lado las dos
ecuaciones que ya teníamos pero ahora
nos falta calcular la derivada parcial
de l con respecto a la anb da y cuántos
eso bueno pues vamos a bajar un poco la
pantalla para calcularla vamos a
calcular la derivada parcial de l con
respecto a landa
y lo primero que quiero que observes es
que toda esta función r depende de x y
depende de james por lo tanto no va a
tener nada de lambda involucrado aquí es
meramente una función que depende de x
de jane por lo tanto la derivada parcial
de esto con respecto a lambda es cero es
una constante por lo tanto se va y aquí
me quedarían menos menos es este menos
de aquí y ahora tengo algo por lambda si
cálculo la derivada de una constante
porque nada de esto depende de lambda
que multiplica a lambda me quedaría
simplemente la constante entonces esto
sería p de equis bien ok esto
- bien y aquí tenemos un paréntesis
menos b ok y si ahora hacemos esto de
aquí igual a cero esto de aquí igual a
cero y si observas esto quiere decir que
esta parte de aquí tiene que ser igual a
cero o dicho de otra manera
ven la función pm que depende de x y de
james tiene que ser igual a esta b
minúscula a esta constante que que crees
es justo lo que tenemos aquí llegamos a
la tercera ecuación que veíamos en los
otros vídeos acabamos de encontrar la
ecuación de restricción así que gracias
a establecer esta forma que tenemos aquí
el gradiente de lambda igual a cero
tenemos una forma muy compacta de
escribir estas tres ecuaciones estas
tres ecuaciones que antes teníamos por
separado
y todo esto recuerdan era el ejercicio
de optimización con restricción y bueno
quiero enfatizar que en la práctica tal
vez sea mucho más fácil resolver las
estas tres por separado tal vez aquí lo
que estamos haciendo es envolviendo todo
para después desenvolverlo pero el
objetivo de esto o la razón por la cual
creo que esto es un modelo muy útil es
que las computadoras a menudo pueden
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones de una
manera muy rápida y esto porque las
computadoras ven el gradiente de una
función igual a cero por lo tanto no se
preguntan cuál es el máximo de la
función cuál es
mínimo de la función o si tenemos una
función de reflexión o un ejercicio de
optimización con restricciones
simplemente tienen un gradiente que
tienen que hacer igual a cero bueno por
ahora los voy a dejar en este vídeo pero
en el siguiente vídeo les voy a hablar
sobre esta lambda que tenemos aquí y
vamos a ver cómo está lambda no es
simplemente una variable fantasma de
hecho tiene una interpretación muy
agradable para un ejercicio con
restricción dado como éste